this is back son  it was the home of your grandparents and  their grandparents before then but out  there beyond the age of the water-wise  the whole of the Dragons and I believe  the sure destiny to one day find this  hidden world  you do know my leg isn't a chew toy  don't you is this what you want yeah  okay  how am I supposed to get down hey buddy  wait up he's not the only one  [Music]  another night Furies more like a right  I'm night theory  yeah yours is better probably there is  an armada with enough cages for all of  our dragon vein  this is a new kind of element we need to  find the hidden world I wouldn't destroy  everything you love  it'll nothing without your grandma if  primo succeeds there won't be any  dragons left and it's up to us to put an  end to it so what are you gonna do about  it  suit up game we have one shot you  brought a baby to a battle it couldn't  find a sitter  in the hidden world really touchy right  but inside  well what Kunis not a word  [Music]  you